elle se bat pour son pays depuis 2014 au
Léna biloserska est l'un des visages
féminins de l'armée ukrainienne
désormais lieutenant elle se prépare à
affronter les troupes russes à Kiev elle
s'exprime pour France 24 au téléphone
pour des raisons de sécurité
je pense que dans
quel première ligne
est-ce que j'espère en tout cas car
c'est mon pays c'est ma terre je veux la
défendre je suis obligé de la défendre
j'ai suffisamment d'expérience de combat
et je pense que chaque citoyen ukrainien
qui est capable de tenir une arme doit
en prendre une et aller se battre
c'est grâce à Olena que les femmes
ukrainiennes peuvent désormais combattre
au sein de l'armée quand elle s'est
engagée dans la guerre qui se déroulée
dans l'est de l'Ukraine en 2014 les
femmes ne pouvaient pas occuper de poste
de combat elle a donc servi dans un
bataillon de volontaire
militante de l'égalité femme homme au
Léna a été l'une des six femmes
combattantes à apparaître dans le
documentaire le bataillon invisible
la loi a changé en 2016 et au Léna a
officiellement rejoint l'armée
ukrainienne
âgé de 42 ans et la constaté une
évolution des mentalités depuis 2014
lorsque les hommes soldats étaient
surpris de l'avoir sur le front
il me demandait toujours
êtes-vous médecin ou tireuse d'élite
et maintenant l'armée s'est habituée à
laisser de la place aux femmes
artilleuse ingénieur
je connais même deux ou trois femmes qui
commandent des tanks
[Musique]
a changé et la société a changé
je pense que l'armée ukrainienne et la
société ukrainienne sont devenus plus
fortes avec des femmes fortes
et un droit pour la femme pas une
obligation comme elle elles sont de plus
en plus nombreuses à rejoindre l'armée
depuis la récente invasions russe
qu'elle soit députée ou ancienne
mi-sukraine